there's a TENS of millions of people
literally whose credit history and it
doesn't actually reflect how they have
behaved in the past one of the most
interesting parts of these Market
downturns is you have to transition from
the peacetime CEO to the wartime CEO
what do you do inside the company itself
I am actually much better wartime CEO
than a peacetime CEO you definitely have
to be made of a certain high density
fiber to survive the ups and downs you
basically just assume that your job
today is to survive a new job tomorrow
is to win in a really really big way
that hopefully benefits the world all
right guys bang bang I've got Max here
with me Max I thought a great place to
start would be this idea of a new credit
score uh obviously the idea of the old
credit score uh most of the financial
system is built on you've had personal
experience and also built an entire
company around this idea of creating a
new one help explain what you think the
problems are with the old one and why we
need a new one
um probably the most problematic thing
with the old credit score is that
it just doesn't really
take into account that people's
borrowing
habits and approaches have changed so
this is very recursive but uh the npl
itself majority of the pain four
products that you see are just not
included in the calculation of your FICO
score or Advantage score and so that
alone is a bunch of people's significant
borrowing activity now and even if
you've paid every one of those loans
back on time
be paying for just doesn't even appear
in your credit history or your credit
score in the Consumer Financial
Financial Protection Bureau recently
sort of opined on it and basically said
hey would be really good if the industry
would start reporting that so I think
it's going to change for the better
relatively soon but for this to really
change the companies that use those
scores and compute those scores actually
have to um
to change their behavior but even before
the npl
you know the FICO score which is the the
traditional Fair Isaac's company
um so the the lingua Franca of borrowing
just
would update very slowly I mean these
days actually I think it updates a
little bit faster but back when I had my
own brushes with the uh card scoring uh
um problems if you will um I think it
took me something like 10 years to get
rid of a
black mark I had caused
to myself in college by uh running out
of money and not being able to pay my
bills so
just a slow updating lack of uh data
sources that
really should be included
um
lack of familiarity with how younger
Generations use credit
and the fact that an enormous number of
people probably the most important
because I should have started there
something like 30 to 50 million
Americans have something that's just not
really
reflected at all of how they behave and
who they are and there's many different
reasons why the information isn't
accurate there are mistakes in reporting
their data doesn't get included
correctly etc etc But ultimately there's
a TENS of millions of people literally
whose credit history and therefore
credit score just doesn't actually
reflect
how they have behaved in the past when
they borrowed money or in fact maybe
just doesn't have any information at all
and they're completely excluded from a
standard borrowing systems so what's
interesting about this is you're
highlighting a disjointment if you will
there's people who are doing activities
uh and then the old systems don't
account for that either they're
inaccurate they're slow they're whatever
the problem is
um what I'm fascinated with and I've
been talking about for you know two
years now or so is we see this across
the economy it's not just in the credit
score so think of inflation as an
example as well where we still have
people going into the grocery store with
like a pad and paper and writing down
you know what the change in prices are
uh but it seems like whether it's a
company like yours or other companies in
the fintech sector you have much more
real-time information at point of sale
you know what people are paying you know
what the cost of of change month over
month year over year when you zoom out
and so not just credit score whether
it's inflation calculations or whatever
is the market ripe for just kind of like
hey we have to digitize we have to
modernize and like real-time information
should now be the foundation for all of
these different calculations and kind of
data points that are being presented and
people are using to make decisions
yeah that's a a very good observation
and
I think about a decade ago I had this
thesis that
the transition from analog to digital
will create incredible opportunities for
companies and affirm is certainly one
version of this idea and Credit Data but
the reality of analog data
it's just really
irregular and error-prone and sort of
fuzzy around the edges and
highly likely to be an accurate even if
it seems accurate and so
I think it's very very hard to have a
wholesale replacement of analog systems
with digital systems and so we're doing
a piecemeal
which creates opportunities because if
you figure out a clever way of
accelerating part of the industry a
segment or just a
a flavor of analog and push it into
digital wholesale you'll suddenly be in
possession of an information Advantage
which you know I gotta add the six
thousand or sixty five thousand point of
view just gives you an opportunity to to
to Arbitrage that
but I don't know if there's a way one
can imagine to go from our still pretty
analog lives to fully digital
just really really quickly and I think
we're just gonna keep stumbling through
it in many ways
one of the things that makes China so
interesting as a society
they came from a truly analog economy so
analog that transition to digital wasn't
a choice it was a sort of a moral
imperative like you can't have a country
that big with that many
changes that the many systems and just
slowly move from analog to digital you
just have to do it wholesale and
combined with a centralized government
in that particular scenario I actually
think it helped them but when you I talk
to my friends in Shanghai
we talk about payments of course and uh
it's shocking sort of the level of
innovation they see there and it's
always falls right back into this idea
well they have access to all this data
and it's really accurate and everyone's
on board with it there's no cards they
just all comes from your phone and so on
what's fascinating to me about you
specifically is that you're working on a
very hard problem there's like the
problem in front of you and then there's
the broader thing that we just talked
about but also you have been able to
navigate good times and bad times over
and over and over again and so you 2000
uh Tech boom and bust then you've got
the 2008 Global financial crisis we now
are in this thing I don't even yet know
if people can really describe what it is
how long it'll last how bad it'll be
whatever
um what are some of the lessons maybe
from the past Market downturns that you
now are implementing whether it's
personally or at a firm in terms of
actually running the organizations that
other people could learn from definitely
uh lots of learnings
um
you definitely have to be made of a
certain
high density fiber
to survive the ups and downs I think
that there's no there's no getting
around that the The Knocks sometimes are
very hard and sometimes they get even
harder and
you're not prepared to take the beating
and get up and go back to fighting
um you should stay on the floor and it
sucks to fail and I failed enough times
to know just how painful it is and how
frustrating it can be to be on the floor
and realize that you really aren't going
to be able to get up but I choose to get
up every time even sometimes it means a
failed company or two
um so that that's sort of the the the
the Hard Knocks advice I guess
um a couple of maybe more practical ones
as the leader
I've realized that everybody approaches
kind of the the punch in the face
scenario
differently and sometimes I punch into
faces like this happened and now we have
to deal and we have a day left and you
know Etc sometimes it's kind of the
dread of oh wow the recession is really
coming and people are going to have a
harder time paying their bills and well
that's going to be interesting and
in both of the scenarios you kind of
realize that there's going to get a lot
tougher whatever hard you think you're
experiencing right now the future is not
going to be easier
and
the only way to cope with that is you
kind of have to step back and
try to get through the first two stages
you know why is this happening why is it
happening to me
and
quickly get to all right so what does
the solution look like and in the ideal
world even okay is this an opportunity
if it's really difficult it's probably
really difficult for everyone so am I
going to be able to extract a
competitive advantage or something might
change for the better for us more so
than our competitors and as a human you
can't
completely shake off the why is this
happening why is it happening to me and
why is it happening to me now
what I do to deserve this
you have to develop skills to cope with
that moment and everybody does it
differently
in my case
I train myself over the years and
decades to sort of say all right
just do nothing for a few minutes just
let the information sink it is not going
to be good it's not gonna go away so I'm
gonna get better but any emotional
reaction in the moment isn't going to
fix it for you and so just let it watch
over you for a moment or two
it's probably the case you're missing
some information anyway give yourself a
chance to absorb it and you'll move
right on to the what's the solution and
might this even be beneficial
and so
that that's a really important skill
that I actually have to train myself for
because in the past certainly being
the personality of entrepreneur is that
this happened jump into action and you
may well miss a piece of data that will
later on prove crucial
um
in terms of just practical advice for
how do you cope with downturns
assume they're always coming raise
enough money
deal with the
realities of unexpected loss of Revenue
loss of growth whatever the metric you
care about rationally you can't allow
yourself to be emotional you can't allow
yourself to wallow and you know sort of
looping on why is this happening to me
now is the worst thing you can do
because then you're not acting
um
and um two other most important things
people are the most important
thing in the world
um
by far and so if you compromise your
relationships with people you care about
in the moment of impact or as you deal
with impact
you're ultimately going to regret it
very much and so that is just a really
important thing it doesn't mean that you
can't won't have to make hard choices
but if you do it
by putting aside your feelings and
thoughts about humans that surround you
your team people that you work with your
partners you're absolutely going to
regret it very badly and so that's just
a thing to be very mindful all the time
most people don't need reminding of that
but some people feel like they need to
act extra tough and ruthless in moments
of difficulty and you have to be tough
and you have to be ruthless but you have
to continuously remember that you're not
the only human on the planet
and uh
two
you have to
try to ask the question what does it
look like
if I compromise any of my values to
to accomplish the whatever survival goal
I have and nine times out of ten the
answer you will deeply regret that and
so in in sort of my absolutist rule book
people and values are immutable can't
change them I think that's maybe two
maximalist of an advice and so
you have to uh you have to ask the
question you know what am I doing why am
I doing it but ultimately if you're
poking around your core values and
thinking like might I relax one of those
things
that that's that's a real problem and I
strongly advise against that
it's a very long-winded answer no it's
great and I I think that you've learned
a lot one of the most interesting parts
of these Market downturns is you have to
transition from like uh what many people
would call it the peacetime CEO to the
wartime CEO and you're hinting at this a
little bit what do you do inside the
company itself like is there like a day
where you declare okay I'm now a wartime
CEO and everyone's like Hey we're going
to to war you know essentially or is it
somewhat more of a slower transition as
you realize things are getting worse
uh so it turns out
[Music]
um
I am actually much better as a wartime
CEO than a peacetime CEO I found over
the years that uh if it's really peace
time I start getting very restless and I
kind of look around for war and it's a
little bit of a
Samurai complex I'm a big fan of Samurai
genre and and stories and and
Etc the noble Warrior is uh something
that I at least
percent to identify with but uh
there's lots of stories from medieval
Japan where Samurai would get restless
and they would have to go find an enemy
because otherwise they just started
slaughtering each other and I I don't
Slaughter my team or or at least
self-destruct but I'm definitely more
Restless in peacetime than I'm in
Wartime
um it's actually a really important
skill for CEO so the thing that happens
in peacetime is the team becomes
comfortable with the level of crises
that they have to deal with kind of at a
retail level a different thing peacem
and wartime is fundamentally just a
the frequency of Crisis and the
wholesale nature of it versus the retail
nature of it and so
if
most CEOs I know really struggle in this
transition where you're like more and
more
hits on the uh you know sidewalls of of
the ship is this a crisis is this a war
and for most of us I think the tendency
even if you sort of enjoy the wartime
intensity say well okay this is
problematic but you know we're not like
quite declare you know DEFCON 5 or
whatever
the number is and I found over the years
that it's actually much healthier to
just say okay things have changed
the pivot 2 wartime mentality isn't
going to be
careful and deliberate we're going to
have to declare that this is in fact our
time we're fighting for our lives
there's lots of problems out there and
we're gonna beat the enemy or survive
the the storm
but it's happening now it's not it's not
happening slowly and
I've experimented with messaging over
the years I found that if you try to
peanut butter a little bit more
carefully you just ultimately get very
frustrated not everybody's on the same
page so you kind of have to bring
everyone along and as a wartime CEO the
number one thing you have to do is
communicate and communicate clearly
communicate well and
so long as you're clear about why
certain things are no longer true and
certain behaviors are no longer
going to fly
some people might say well that's not
what I came here to do but those that
thrive in
kind of this sharp black and white
scenarios
will probably appreciate you for for
being clear and appreciate the moment to
to shine and embrace the uh embrace the
struggle ahead
as you're doing this you're a publicly
traded company and so there's everyone
and their mom has an opinion there's
plenty of critics out there they're
looking at a stock price that moves hour
to hour day to day uh your reaction
alone is kind of hey that's uh very
antithetical I think to like somebody
who has long-term Vision trying to solve
a big problem
um how have you as a public company CEO
really balanced if I was just building a
company or building a solution you know
there's this long-term mentality but you
do have to manage the public
expectations and the critics and and all
that it's like what lessons have you
learned there over the years this
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer and the
eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
an eat sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep in public for less than
eight quarter hours and so uh it's
probably a little too early to ask me
for a rule book of how to be a public
company
um CEO with a
with a great plan
um
I think probably the most important
thing
as a public company CEO anyway is to
understand who your major shareholders
are I think I'm still my own one of the
larger shareholders for sure and so
ultimately
I have
if not the most
quite a lot to lose
um or gain from the performance of a
firm as a long-term investment I think
my heart goes out to day traders that
lose or make money on a firm but I spent
less than a nanosecond actually thinking
about them I very much care about making
return on investment for my long-term
shareholders
of which I am one of which many most of
our employees are
and so
the notion that well I got a vision and
I just got to go there and I don't care
about the stock price I think it's
disingenuous this is the capitalist
Enterprise we've raised quite a lot of
money a lot of those Shares are still
owned by people who gave us the money to
build this company and it's my duty and
job to give them an excellent return and
that's I certainly intend to do
the good news or the comforting news is
that when we raise the money we told
them the same story over and over again
the very Vision that we put in our S1
was in our first financing deck it's
actually sort of insane I don't think
I've ever run a company that did not
pivot except for every single project
I've ever had and this is I lost count
but this is in the teens of companies
that I started and everyone except for
this one at some point and said yeah
we're really not going to do this we're
going to do this something else and not
a firm has always been in this honest
Financial products Mission and we
continue to do so so the story has never
changed people that bought our shares in
series a through the IPO have all heard
the same thing we promised them that we
will do our absolute DARS to make an
exceptional return on their investment
and that is the plan and they have seen
the plan and have seen the story that we
think will get us there we keep on
growing we keep on printing really good
results
the vicissitudes of the stock market are
sometimes frustrating in a sense that
you you feel disoriented by the uh by
the dizziness of
we post a great quarter the market
penalizes it for it
there's a some other random signal and
uh suddenly the market rewards it for it
and like well did I do this or did some
external Factor have had a a hand in
this and
ultimately I keep myself focused by
being frustrated with teachers are
they're not shipping fast enough or
conversion rates that are not as good as
I want them to be and uh
pennies that we leave on the floor when
we should be picking them up things like
that and so I'm very very internally
focused and goal driven for the company
in the service of the strategy that
comes from the mission
it doesn't hurt to have total conviction
that's what we're doing is important and
believe that we're pursuing the mission
in with the right strategy I think once
you start losing faith in your strategy
or your mission
that's when you get really really
tailspun like at that point you really
should rethink everything and that's
when you start listening to the voices
outside her screaming at you saying you
should do extra why because obviously
you're an idiot and I'm I'm pretty far
from from uh feeling that way so I'm I'm
quite tanguine so as you built this
business one of the things that I've
seen uh talked about publicly is a focus
on building the right culture and I
think of culture as something that
attracts the right Talent it kind of
rejects certain types of talent how do
you think about building that in today's
day and age right it's 2022 there's all
kinds of chaos going on like how do you
kind of stay true to what that culture
is over years where many people I think
would argue just like Society has been
changing as well right so kind of
everything's moving around you how do
you keep a culture that attracts the
people you're looking for to help you on
this mission
it's a great question
um and by the way I think in that
particular domain
I'm still very much in learning mode and
everything I thought I knew changed with
the pandemic
and everything I know changes with every
100 employees maybe every 500 employees
that we had when we were tiny it was
really easy to enforce the culture and I
I built the affirm card culture very
very deliberately I had obviously lots
of
experience with building teams in the
past some I thought were spectacular
others were
less so and I had to fix culture
it's really really hard to rewrite your
culture it's basically a mass
layoff if you end up thinking my God you
know culture is way broken more than
half the people are not the way
interacting the way that you think they
should be and so I was very fortunate a
firm was very deliberately built we
wrote down our core values before we
incorporated the company we wrote down
our mission which has never changed so
all of that the foundation is right
as you get larger you have to over
communicate it you have to continuously
reiterate what it means and the amount
of drift in interpretation of the core
values and the mission is staggering
like you literally look away and people
say well you said this in our core
values and here's how I interpret it and
when you're 100 company you can say no
no that's just silly like that's not
actually what I mean
if you have 2 600 employees which is
roughly where we are you don't get to
hear that you don't get to say oh wait
hang on a second that's just not right
and so you have to over communicate as
much as possible
what do you really mean and a lot of
times it comes down to all right so
here's the situation in front of us or
in front of an employee that you may
have never met or I have never met
and they're thinking about making this
really tough moral choice
and they think they fully understand
what it means for the backbone of our
company to stay straight and narrow and
I think those we have done an
exceptionally good job just hammering
like no we will never screw our
consumers like there's lots of ways to
make money in this world and there are
things we will not do and some others do
it and others even have really good
explanations for why they do it and we
will not we just don't think it's right
and that's off limits and I would be
shocked if people within a firm were
like well but like one day we'll do
those things like no we won't like I
think Pitchfork will come out as soon as
somebody suggests that and they'll be
carried out from from their Zoom room
but in more subtle matters
like you know one of the really
interesting uh things to to debate is
when so one of our core values is um
people come first
and um it's really tempting to say it's
older people and then you have a sorting
function well so I'm a people in Europe
people and we have some employees that
are people and most of them all of them
maybe and then the way up for consumers
and lots of others and the original
meaning of the core value people come
first is
very very clearly articulated in the the
first set of writings that I did about
affirm and that is we put our borrowers
ahead of ourselves we will not take
advantage of them we will not make money
when they are in trouble and so on and
so forth
and
just explaining that very very clearly
and making sure people really understand
very deeply that ultimately we are a
service organization we are serving a
consumer that has needs and we choose to
place their needs ahead of our own
that's just how it's meant to be and
that's not the easiest thing to absorb
for some I think you have a
yeah
and on the other side of this is
actually this notion of iron well if
that's really true like why aren't we a
non-profit and like I have some very
strong words to uh to describe why we're
not uh and uh and and so anyways these
are all kind of maybe very
low-level examples of
how the stuff gets harder and harder as
you get
larger in size because inevitable these
conversations occur when you're not in
the room and so it's my job to teach all
of my directs and their job to teach
their directs and so on and so so long
as the conversation keeps going and the
messages are repeated in consistent ways
and it it does really well and survives
and I think we've done a good job I
think it's a lot harder in Zoom rooms
because you just don't quite have as
much interaction in real time I was just
going to ask uh I worked at Facebook for
a couple years and what has now become
somewhat of a joke but there was
literally posters you know move fast and
break things done this better than
perfect like you would walk down the
hall it was like an indoctrination of
certain whether they were actual values
or or like certain phrases that uh kind
of reinforced what the company was about
that's great when you actually have
hallways but if you're on Zoom uh I
don't see any posters behind your head
that are like reinforcing the company
values so how do you do it
um
I think that's a
a I was going to show you my virtual
background during the early days of the
pandemic but I think that this is a
different laptop I uh when pandemic just
began and we suddenly went into the zoom
land I was like what do I do to sort of
tell people
something you know this this is all
these pixels behind me and um
um I I had the uh Hitchhiker's Guide uh
cover with the big done Panic on it as
my as my background for quite some time
it's been long enough in The Strange
World of Zoom that uh I don't even have
to file anymore I'm not sure where the
uh the image map was
um so I think the
couple of thoughts on how do you how do
you um preserve the culture or amplify
the culture in a world where you don't
have always which I think is is pretty
uh pretty great important question
it's easier the cheat code on preserving
the culture is you make it very explicit
in your interviewing process and your
recruiting process that there's a
certain flavor of how we do and do not
do things here that we really care about
certain decisions a lot and maybe you
don't care about others as much and you
self-select or you pre-select the people
who join
to
understand
what this is this place is all about
like we are building a profitable
capitalist Enterprise we take great
pride in it and yet we also are very
very hell-bent on treating our borrowers
right delivering value to emerging
partners
in not cheating by creating
fees and hidden charges the way the
industry has sort of chosen to cheat and
you have to go through the trouble of
explaining that and for some people I
think it might be a well maybe I don't
want to work here because you want
maximize profit by any means necessary
and that's outside of
my
core values and or and maybe it's
equally Deployable people like well wait
a second why are you insisting on making
profit and we insist on on that so
making sure the culture is
self-perpetuating through the
interviewing process is one of the ways
you can
maybe make it a little bit easier in the
world with no hallways the
other way in the world with no hallways
is has been certainly my my play for the
last uh several months since the
pandemic has been a little bit easier to
navigate
is you travel we have a lot of offices
around the world now
um my next week will be in Poland where
we have an office which will be really
exciting I haven't seen that one yet but
the week before was in Chicago and the
one a couple of weeks prior was in New
York and
in even in the world where most people
are in their office sort of a Tuesday
through Thursday these days as opposed
to a full week it's just really really
great to have a moment to interact with
real humans and to do do my part and
help them reinforce the culture and I
don't know if we will ever have
too many posters just because no not
enough time to to look at them all but
uh conversations are more valuable than
posters and walls in my opinion so we
encourage people to travel we encourage
people to get together in person we have
lots of off-sites where teams get
together and spend as much time
interacting just kind of reinforcing the
culture with each other
as they do working so I think that you
in aggregate I don't think it's an
impossible task but it's certainly
something you have to be very deliberate
about
one of my last questions for you uh you
are incredibly intelligent you're very
kind of thoughtful I think in a lot of
uh uh your public appearances and our
conversation here
um and you have been part of a number of
different teams that I think people
really look up to and they say hey you
guys have been successful you've been
able to attract other smart intelligent
hard-working people what do you
personally do to learn are you reading
books in your free time are you
listening to podcasts are you uh doing
you know something that no one's ever
heard of before like what are you doing
given that you have this day job that
obviously has all this pressure
associated with it but how do you learn
on a day-to-day basis
it's a great question
um probably the single most
useful predictor of success that I have
discerned in in my decades hanging
around this this planet
um
is curiosity
combined with intelligence is just a
really really good prediction of success
maybe more so curiosity than than
anything else really and I Am Naturally
curious so it's helpful I don't have to
work too hard at
wanting to learn more
um
I do I do a fair amount uh I read quite
a lot we used to uh
used to publish with Max's reading
newsletter to affirmers just to uh keep
them guessing what the next book will be
I'm fairly Omniverse
um
uh for when we did have hallways we had
a bookshelf where it could be a couple
of copies of whatever it is that I was
gorging myself on I tend to read
multiple books at a time
um one cool Pro tip
um so if you read books on Kindle
you should buy the Kindle plus audible
bundle because Kindle plus audible
tracks where you are reading digitally
and you can literally go from I'm
reading this on my phone now I have to
drive I'm going to flip it over to
Audible and have it read to me so I can
go through a book very very quickly
um I of course listen to things on one
and a half time speeds and or faster if
I can help it
um I found that there's an incredible
amount of really great content on
YouTube so I watch tons of lectures on
YouTube and other sources about YouTube
is mostly free
um
I listened to a lot of podcasts I
actually quite enjoy the genre I thought
I would hate it but uh it turns out that
it's it's quite nice good work there
um
I
definitely rabbit hole into Wikipedia
way too often uh I it's it's a it's a
pretty fun Pastime and then I tend to
try to find creative outlets for myself
that require
learning so for example I studied music
as a kid and I hadn't really gone back
to it in quite some time and then
recently I decided that to sort of
exercise the other side of the brain I
have to go deep into music and so I've
been learning how to use various
digital audio workstation software and
reading and watching music theory
lectures and all kinds of stuff which
there's only so many minutes per day to
do it but it just forces you to exercise
a learning muscle in the other part of
the brain that is not related to things
like discounted cash flow and machine
learning based underwriting and like all
the stuff that I do day in and day out
for work
and that that seems to help you can
sometimes draw parallels where you say
oh I saw this really interesting random
thing about music theory and it's
nothing like underwriting except there's
some similarity maybe I should go pull
on that for a little while and so that I
I try to learn as much as I can every
day I highly recommend it
being curious was really good
um
maybe the other one last random bit of
advice
and this is applicable to every question
you ask perhaps
um
maybe two parts um one being cynical is
just a loss proposition it's like a
lose-lose proposition there's no way to
win if you're a cynic uh the Greeks
headed rights cynic means dog-like and
uh I there's nothing good about being
being cynical that said
cynicism is kind of an approximation for
evaluation of risk you sort of look at
the world and say oh man nothing's going
to work out this sucks like we're
already done and like sort of the
ultimate cynicism you know like where's
the nearest bathtub I need a you know a
razor blade and um
that that's a terrible way to live and I
strongly advise against it that said you
have to be eyes wide open like when
you're looking at the world and you're
saying uh the big iceberg is floating in
the water or you can't say Full Speed
Ahead you have to figure out a way to
get around it and so I founded the
posture of short-term
risk averse trying to figure out how to
not hit the iceberg that's right in
front of you while being extraordinarily
optimistic about the future and taking
outsized risk bets on the future
outcomes has worked really well for me
where you basically just assume that
your job today is to survive a new job
tomorrow is to win in a really really
big way that hopefully benefits the
world
that's combined with curiosity you can
get reasonably far I love that uh in a
way you've basically made learning a
hobby like you're you to do all of that
right you're just constantly learning I
tend to find myself doing the same thing
and it really upsets people in my life
who are like I don't want to watch
YouTube anymore right and I'm like no no
but like why would we watch the other
thing like yeah I think it's making us
Dumber uh I do I have a young daughter
and uh uh I'm trying to train her like
why don't you also watch YouTube rather
than cartoons that's uh yeah I have a I
have an 11 and a almost 13 year old and
they are unfortunate the victims I'm
like oh my God I just saw this amazing
obscure video that taught me something
that you really really have to know
let's watch this together it's this
crazy chess opening I've never heard of
what are you talking about there's Tick
Tock yeah exactly uh my last question
for you is a fun one uh I I'm always
fascinated by uh people's belief do you
think aliens are real and not only yes
or no but like how do you kind to think
through that problem which we may never
get an answer to or maybe we're going to
get an answer you know sooner than we'd
like but how do you think about whether
aliens are real or not
I can't say I spend too much time
thinking about the binary answer to the
question so I'm a huge fan of Science
Fiction and in my cocoa spare time I
read an inordinate amount of Science
Fiction I'm quite a big fan of going
quite a hard sci-fi where aliens are
real and rocket ships travel you know
from world to world
I think the world will be so much more
boring if this all turned out to be not
true like I just don't want to
learn
today which unfortunately I think it's
impossible to really learn that there's
nothing else out there it's just us
the point of view that no it really is
it's just us and there's no one nothing
intelligent lots of
cold rocks and
elements floating around and nothingness
and we're in the very very center of it
all sitting around trying to solve our
petty little problems it's very boring
and I I choose to uh I choose to hope
that it's better than that I've
obviously read all the various uh
thought experiments sort of have you
convince yourself that uh
that at a certain scale the
probabilities approach 100 and on all of
that
um
I'm not sure we understand
our surroundings so well that any of
those approximations are really to be
relied upon
but from the sort of uh what would be
more interesting like what would satisfy
my curiosity
kind of want to believe they're real
right
I mean yeah it would be uh one boring
but also two uh
kind of feels like that's the last New
World right like kind of Earth is uh to
some degree discovered yeah sure there's
still maybe some Pockets that we don't
know as much about and things like the
ocean or whatever but it does feel like
the the frontier of space and whether
there's life or Not Another planets all
that kind of stuff
um aspiration is important for Humanity
and it gives us something to look
forward to and build towards and stuff
like that so it would be kind of
depressing if all of a sudden it was
like hey uh actually it's just like a
wall like you can't go past it or
something uh I think that would be a sad
a sad answer
yeah there's also really good literature
that shows that
at least attempts to prove that what
we've had here assuming you believe in
some version of evolution is just not
that special like there's all these
things that happen but they're all kind
of basic chemical reactions and lots of
time
and not even that much time and so if
you kind of subscribe to
well understood principles of
basic physics
there's been enough time in all sorts of
places to have variants of evolution
take place
the the fact or the the idea hopefully
not the fact that we are the one branch
of the Precision tree the possibility
tree that actually got to intelligent
life
is depressing and boring and
would be a lot more fun if if or not the
case now there's also only obvious world
and then aliens show up and they don't
like us and you have to uh deal with
Independence Day scenarios uh the the
infamous movie
um
I think
like my
this is another belief but uh I think
generally speaking most intelligent
species even as they approach our
intelligence assuming at the moment at
least we are the smartest ones we know
they Trend towards good so if you serve
the smarter you get I think the more
benevolent and
you replace your aggression with
curiosity and if that's true we're
certainly not capable today of
interstellar travel and to do that the
energy you have to musture is roughly
equivalent to sort of the planetary
energy sources like we could probably
travel Interstellar if we could gather
up all the energy on Earth
and and start propelling ourselves that
way so whoever shows up here if they do
so first they'll have to be a lot more
intelligent than us and if that's the
case my guess and belief is that they
will have progressed to being more and
more benign and so maybe they'll show up
and you know we'll teach us interesting
things or we'll make great pets yeah
one or the other I love it uh Max listen
thank you so much for taking the time to
do this uh it is awesome to see what you
guys are building with the firm and then
you have decades and Decades of
experience I think a lot of people can
learn from so hopefully they got
something out of this and we will
definitely do it again in the future
second thanks for having me